Shure: 听过吗啊
Shure: Heard it, huh?
Alice:听过
Alice: Yeah, I've heard it.
Katrina: 真没听过
Katrina: I've never heard it.
Katrina: 听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard it?
Tasha:谁没听过
Tasha: Who hasn't heard it?
Alice:好像听过又好像没听过呢
Alice: Feels like I've heard it, but also feels like I haven't.
Tasha:好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Shure: 朴树的
Shure: It's by Pu Shu.
Shure: 这首就比较欢快
Shure: This one is more upbeat.
Shure: 这是备选一
Shure: This is option one.
Katrina: 备选二是什么
Katrina: What's option two?
Katrina: 备选二是开心超人
Katrina: Is option two "Happy Superman"?
Shure: 开心超人
Shure: "Happy Superman."
Shure: 大家小时候看过吗
Shure: Did you all watch it when you were kids?
Shure: 完了你这
Shure: Oh no, you...
Shure: 明显跟我们有点代沟啊哈哈
Shure: Clearly, there's a bit of a generation gap, haha.
Alice:开心往前飞
Alice: "Happy Flying Forward."
Katrina: 对对对就是这首歌
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, that's the song.
Jake:然后还有这是个动画片吗
Jake: And this is a cartoon, right?
Shure: 对动画片
Shure: Yeah, a cartoon.
Jake:我确实也不知道
Jake: I really don't know it.
Lucia:那行咱俩没代沟哈哈哈
Lucia: Well, at least we're on the same page, haha.
Jake:这这这长什么样啊
Jake: What's it look like?
Jake:里边的角色
Jake: The characters in it?
Shure: 就是那个红色的
Shure: It's the red one.
Shure: 那个叫开心超人
Shure: It's called "Happy Superman."
Jake:你认识这些这些玩意吗
Jake: Do you know these things?
Lucia:哦我见过
Lucia: Oh, I've seen it.
Jake:完了还是有带差
Jake: Well, there's still a gap.
Lucia:但我没但我没看过
Lucia: But I've never watched it.
Lucia:应该
Lucia: Probably.
Jake:我见都没见过
Jake: I've never even seen it.
Jake:你知道这玩意吗
Jake: Do you know this stuff?
Jake:哦水平还是比我高的
Jake: Oh, you know more than me.
Shure: 那还有下一首是这个
Shure: So, the next song is this one.
Katrina: 你跳舞吗
Katrina: Do you dance?
Katrina: 不会吧
Katrina: No way.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 别猜哈
Shure: Don't guess.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 有点疑惑了
Katrina: I'm a bit confused.
Katrina: 哈哈哈好
Katrina: Haha, okay.
Jake:我这个虽然没听过但是很好唱的感觉
Jake: I've never heard this, but it feels easy to sing.
Shure: 对很好唱
Shure: Yeah, it's easy to sing.
Katrina: 三选一当开头
Katrina: Pick one out of three for the opening.
Katrina: 三选一
Katrina: One out of three.
Shure: 咱们听过最多的就是那个
Shure: The one we've heard the most is that one.
Lucia: 难忘今宵
Lucia: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Katrina: 难忘今宵在最后的我们
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight" is for the end.
Jake:开场难忘今宵
Jake: Start with "Unforgettable Tonight."
Katrina: 开开开场要选
Katrina: No, we have to choose for the opening.
Jake:结束
Jake: Ending.
Jake:欢迎大家
Jake: Welcome everyone.
Lucia: 我投票给雨轩了
Lucia: I voted for Yuxuan.
Lucia:难忘今宵
Lucia: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Lucia:好我一票已经送出去了
Lucia: Okay, my vote is in.
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's great.
Jake:难忘今宵
Jake: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Jake:对对好我是
Jake: Yes, yes, I'm...
Jake:我说开场我说开场我说开场开场对
Jake: I'm saying it for the opening, for the opening, yes.
Katrina: 但是我们要开头这是开场的
Katrina: But we need it for the start, this is for the opening.
Jake:难忘今宵
Jake: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Tasha:难忘今宵是我来搜索看
Tasha: I'll search for "Unforgettable Tonight."
Katrina: 难忘今宵能用吉他弹吗
Katrina: Can we play "Unforgettable Tonight" with a guitar?
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:摇滚难忘今宵
Jake: Rock version of "Unforgettable Tonight."
Jake:可以吗啊要
Jake: Can we? Ah, we need...
Katrina: 那你好交给你了
Katrina: Alright, over to you.
Lucia:租个琴吧
Lucia: Rent a guitar.
Katrina: 他有
Katrina: He has one.
Lucia: 哦那可以
Lucia: Oh, that's fine then.
Shure: 那你怎么再搬回去呢
Shure: But how will you move it back?
Shure: 能卖出去吗
Shure: Can you sell it?
Lucia:你是电钢琴还是电键盘了啊
Lucia: Is it an electric piano or an electric keyboard?
Jake:就三个选项吗
Jake: Just three options?
Katrina: 开场的就三选一
Katrina: For the opening, just one out of three.
Katrina: 三选一都已经选不出来了
Katrina: Can't even choose one out of three.
Lucia:你说竟然没有琴房
Lucia: You mean there's no piano room?
Lucia:好可怜啊拍拍
Lucia: So sad, pat pat.
Jake:在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright then.
Lucia:在沙河
Lucia: In Shahe.
Katrina: 什么东西啊
Katrina: What is it?
Katrina: 公用什么
Katrina: Shared what?
Katrina: 就一个公用钢琴
Katrina: Just one shared piano.
Alice:沙河那个校区吗
Alice: The Shahe campus?
Lucia:还在沙河
Lucia: Still in Shahe.
Katrina: 你自己选
Katrina: You choose for yourself.
Katrina: 你选呗要不你哪个熟练就选哪个
Katrina: You choose, pick the one you are most familiar with.
Lucia:我还以为我们学校琴房要付钱
Lucia: I thought we had to pay for the piano room at our school.
Lucia:已经很不可思议了呢
Lucia: It's already unbelievable.
Shure: 那就
Shure: Then...
Shure: new boy吧大家感觉听的是听过得最多的
Shure: How about "New Boy"? Seems like everyone has heard it the most.
Jake:我们不用付钱
Jake: We don't need to pay.
Jake:因为没有
Jake: Because there's none.
Lucia:你说你说嗯你说
Lucia: You say, you say, yeah, you say.
Jake:不是
Jake: No.
Katrina: 哪个
Lucia:啊 好吧好吧对对对
Lucia: Ah, alright, alright, yes, yes.
Shure: 就来这首new boy好不好
Shure: So, let's do "New Boy", okay?
Katrina: 行牛boy
Katrina: Okay, "New Boy".
Jake:因为没有对
Jake: Because there's none, right.
Lucia:我以为你说在哪不用付钱
Lucia: I thought you were saying where we don't need to pay.
Jake:没有我以为你说你在说牛boy
Jake: No, I thought you were talking about "New Boy".
Shure: 好 记住了吗
Shure: Okay, remember it?
Tasha:new boy是怎么唱
Tasha: How do you sing "New Boy"?
Alice:没
Alice: No.
Lucia:啥
Lucia: What?
Shure: new boy
Shure: "New Boy".
Tasha:哪一首
Tasha: Which song?
Shure: 就是这时的我看见到处是阳光是吧
Shure: It's the one that goes "At this moment, I see sunshine everywhere", right?
Alice:啊这个听过
Alice: Ah, I've heard this one.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 行那就这个
Katrina: Okay, let's do this one.
Shure: 那就这个了
Shure: Let's go with this one then.
Shure: 大家回去多加练习
Shure: Everyone, practice more when you get back.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Lucia:没听过
Lucia: Never heard of it
Alice:是什么这个要开场
Alice: What is this for, the opening?
Tasha:开场对
Tasha: Yes, the opening
Shure: 对开场
Shure: Yes, for the opening
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay
Katrina: 但是我们几个人一起唱
Katrina: But we are singing together
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Katrina: 跑调没关系
Katrina: It's okay if we go off-key
Alice:好 好
Alice: Okay, okay
Katrina: 也没什么人看
Katrina: There aren't many people watching anyway
Shure: 说唱也行你就突然来呦
Shure: Rapping is fine too, you can just jump in
Shure: 就这样也可以
Shure: That's fine too
Lucia:好你说lou那一段这是艰巨任务
Lucia: Okay, that part where you say "lou" is a tough task
Lucia:交给你了
Lucia: It's up to you
Katrina: 然后中
Katrina: And then in the middle
Katrina: 我们本来定的是两首
Katrina: We originally planned for two songs
Katrina: 一手开场欢快一点
Katrina: One for a lively opening
Katrina: 一手中间那种配合晚上那种悠闲
Katrina: And one for the middle, something more relaxed for the evening
Katrina: emo一点的那个
Katrina: Something a bit more emo
Katrina: 选的是perfect和唯一二选一
Katrina: We're choosing between "Perfect" and "Only One"
Katrina: 哎黄老板
Katrina: Hey Nicous
Shure: 你这个一定听过了吧
Shure: You must have heard this one, right?
Shure: 混欧美圈的啊
Shure: You're into Western music, right?
Lucia:啊哪个
Lucia: Which one?
Katrina: 黄老板的perfect
Katrina: Nicous' "Perfect"
Shure: 黄老板的perfect啊
Shure: Nicous' "Perfect"
Lucia:听过但我这个听的不多
Lucia: I've heard it, but not that much
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay
Lucia:黄老板听的最多的应该shape of you
Lucia: The one I listen to the most from Nicous is "Shape of You"
Lucia:哈哈口水干了
Lucia: Haha, my mouth is dry
Alice:哎呀我妈呀哈哈
Alice: Oh my gosh, haha
Lucia:嗯嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm
Katrina: 好像唯一不适合合唱
Katrina: Seems like "Only One" isn't suitable for a chorus
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright
Shure: 那我们要不
Shure: So how about
Shure: 你给大家solo一个女团舞吧
Shure: You solo a girl group dance for everyone?
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice:没有
Alice: No way
Katrina: 我要跳也要拉着你
Katrina: If I dance, I'm dragging you in too
Jake:你要啊
Jake: Do you want it?
Tasha:你要不来一段吧
Tasha: How about you give it a try?
Tasha:哈哈哈你好合适啊
Tasha: Hahaha, you're perfect for it!
Shure: 我不行的
Shure: I can't do it.
Shure: 我害羞
Shure: I'm too shy.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
Katrina: 那就订perfect
Katrina: Then let's book "perfect".
Jake:你跳一个
Jake: You dance.
Shure: perfect
Shure: Perfect.
Jake:然后以后就是
Jake: And then in the future...
Katrina: 中间一一下
Katrina: Just a little in the middle.
Alice:中间的不用合唱吧
Alice: We don't need to do a duet in the middle, right?
Jake:以后这种计算机视觉的会议啊
Jake: For future computer vision conferences...
Katrina: 可以合唱啊
Katrina: We can do a duet.
Jake:就会邀请你
Jake: They will invite you.
Alice:可以合
Alice: We can do it.
Katrina: 要不然就我俩
Katrina: Or it could be just us two.
Katrina: 我俩会笑场
Katrina: We'd probably laugh during it.
Shure: 我就可以当学术蝗虫了是吧
Shure: So I can just be an academic locust, right?
Jake:不是就是会邀请你就去演出
Jake: No, it's just they will invite you to perform.
Jake:当就是你知道那个妮娜
Jake: Just like, you know, Nina...
Shure: 妮娜是
Shure: Who is Nina?
Jake:就是信号处里的那个那个女的啊
Jake: The woman from the signal processing department.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:然后这种顶级会议都会邀请他去
Jake: And they always invite her to these top conferences.
Jake:然后这个
Jake: And then...
Shure: 那这样
Shure: So...
Shure: 以后就顶级会议都会邀请我去是吗
Shure: In the future, top conferences will invite me too, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:真的没有
Jake: Not really.
Shure: 每每次会给报差旅并且
Shure: They will cover travel expenses and...
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure: 部分劳务
Shure: Partial labor costs.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:然后这个说是说土灵奖得主请你上台
Jake: And then they might say, Turing Award winner, please come on stage.
Jake:哇哇
Jake: Wow, wow.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 所以我手机去哪了
Shure: So where did my phone go?
Jake:所以你要不要跳
Jake: So, do you want to dance?
Alice:要的要的
Alice: Yes, yes.
Shure: 我不要我不要
Shure: I don't want it, I don't want it.
Shure: 哈哈哈你不要给我画这些饼
Shure: Hahaha, stop making empty promises to me.
Lucia:跳跳跳你跳
Lucia: Jump, jump, you jump.
Lucia:我站你第二排
Lucia: I'll stand in the second row behind you.
Lucia:就是你在我前面
Lucia: So you'll be in front of me.
Lucia:我站你第二排给你伴舞
Lucia: I'll stand in the second row and dance behind you.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia:实际上那天徐璐正开始跳
Lucia: Actually, that day, when Xu Lu started dancing...
Katrina: 是我偷偷的从排后面下去了
Katrina: I secretly slipped away from the back row.
Katrina: 是吧哈哈
Katrina: Right? Haha.
Alice:我们一共准备三首歌吗
Alice: We have three songs prepared, right?
Shure: 两两首难忘今宵
Shure: Two, two. "Unforgettable Tonight."
Katrina: 难忘今宵
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Shure: 是
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 唱吗
Katrina: Are we singing?
Shure: 拿音响放吧
Shure: Just play it on the speaker.
Katrina: 拿音响放
Katrina: Play it on the speaker.
Katrina: 然后我们就合一合
Katrina: Then we'll sing along.
Katrina: 难忘今宵你先一边收拾碟子一边
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight," you can tidy up the plates while listening.
Jake:按出来啥了
Jake: What did you play?
Shure: 哦f和弦
Shure: Oh, an F chord.
Shure: 行那就这么定了
Shure: Alright, it's settled then.
Shure: 第二首的话
Shure: For the second song...
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Shure: 不是这个不是
Shure: No, not this one.
Shure: 这个perfect大家没听过吧
Shure: This "Perfect," nobody has heard it, right?
Jake:听过
Jake: I have.
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Jake:唱个太多的新歌
Jake: Sing too many new songs.
Jake:新歌新歌
Jake: New songs, new songs.
Jake:不行老歌吧
Jake: No, let's do old songs.
Shure: 这个大家听过吧
Shure: Everyone knows this one, right?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Shure: 大家都听过什么比较舒缓一点的歌
Shure: What slow songs has everyone heard?
Lucia:第二首竟然要舒缓一点的
Lucia: The second song should be a bit slower.
Shure: 对一人报一首
Shure: Yes, everyone suggest one song each.
Alice:想不起来
Alice: Can't remember.
Shure: 舒缓的
Shure: Something soothing.
Shure: 我教大家唱我们乐队的原创歌曲吧
Shure: How about I teach everyone an original song from our band?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 哎那耳熟能详一点的那种
Katrina: How about something more familiar?
Jake:草与虫之歌
Jake: Grass and Insect Song.
Katrina: 那种周杰伦的那种弹唱呗
Katrina: Maybe something like Jay Chou's songs.
Lucia:搞笑
Lucia: Funny.
Lucia:周杰伦的舒缓一些
Lucia: Jay Chou's more soothing ones.
Katrina: 安静然后再叫安静
Katrina: Quiet, then call it Quiet.
Shure: 晴天
Shure: Sunny Day.
Jake:一谋哥
Jake: One Mo Ge.
Shure: 晴天大家听过吗
Shure: Has everyone heard Sunny Day?
Katrina: 谁没听过呀
Katrina: Who hasn't heard it?
Shure: 那不行就这个吧
Shure: Alright, let's go with this one then.
Shure: 我搜一下晴天
Shure: I'll look up Sunny Day.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 在晚上唱晴天
Katrina: Singing Sunny Day at night.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Alice:那就唱夜曲吧
Alice: Then let's sing Nocturne.
Tasha:晚上唱夜曲
Tasha: Singing Nocturne at night.
Jake:晚上唱夜曲
Jake: Singing Nocturne at night.
Alice:晚上唱夜曲
Alice: Singing Nocturne at night.
Katrina: 睛天
Katrina: Sunny Day.
Shure: 好像卡住了
Shure: Seems stuck.
Shure: 啊我知道来吧
Shure: Ah, I got it, let's go.
Shure: OK就是这个样子
Shure: OK, just like this.
Katrina: 你哼一下
Katrina: Hum a bit.
Katrina: 到哪了
Katrina: Where are we?
Katrina: 行那就这首
Katrina: Alright, let's go with this one.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure: 太棒了
Shure: Awesome.
Katrina: 简单
Katrina: Simple.
Katrina: :定了
Shure: 我们定完了
Shure: We've decided.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 到时候收尾就是你钢琴独奏一下
Katrina: At the end, you can do a piano solo.
Tasha:英文歌
Tasha: An English song.
Shure: 新加坡新加坡国语普及率很高
Shure: In Singapore, the use of Mandarin is very common.
Lucia:可以可以我支持
Lucia: Okay, I support that.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 再自由组合呗
Katrina: We can mix and match freely.
Katrina: 想想
Katrina: Think about it.
Katrina: 想唱的或者想弹的就自由组合呗
Katrina: Sing whatever you want or play whatever you want, just mix and match freely.
Katrina: 就是这个
Katrina: That's it.
Katrina: 就是放在晚上的那个环节
Katrina: It's for the evening segment.
Katrina: 就是吃完晚饭那个环节
Katrina: Right after dinner.
Katrina: 也可以邀请别人他们一起
Katrina: You can also invite others to join.
Alice:哎嘉宾到晚上几点结束啊
Alice: Hey, what time do the guests leave at night?
Katrina: 8点
Katrina: 8 o'clock.
Alice:8点
Alice: 8 o'clock.
Alice:他们吃饭吗
Alice: Do they eat?
Alice:需要吃的吧
Alice: They should eat, right?
Katrina: 就是不是说点披萨吗
Katrina: We were talking about ordering pizza, right?
Alice:晚上嗯
Alice: In the evening, hmm.
Jake:傍晚吧对
Jake: In the evening, yes.
Tasha:傍晚达美乐
Tasha: In the evening, Domino's.
Jake:对对对超级大披萨
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, a super large pizza.
Shure: 秋吧蘸点披萨
Shure: Yeah, let's dip some pizza.
Shure: 有那个超级大披
Shure: There's that super large pizza.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 你练习吧
Shure: You practice.
Shure: 我觉得你们的讨论
Shure: I think your discussion...
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 已经有有了一个结果
Shure: ...already has a conclusion.
Lucia:好难夹
Lucia: So hard to pick up.
Shure: 嗯那我们
Shure: Hmm, then we...
Jake:那我们最后干嘛呢
Jake: So what are we doing last?
Jake:最后一天干嘛来着
Jake: What are we doing on the last day?
Jake:先唱这三首歌
Jake: First sing these three songs.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: Then what?
Shure: 先唱两首
Shure: First sing two songs.
Shure: 然后最后放难忘今宵
Shure: Then play "Unforgettable Tonight" at the end.
Shure: 就是散场的时候放难忘今宵
Shure: Play "Unforgettable Tonight" when we're wrapping up.
Jake:好然后先唱两首歌啊
Jake: Okay, then first sing two songs.
Katrina: 其实如果有自己想唱的就到时候
Katrina: Actually, if you want to sing something yourself, then...
Katrina: 反正连伴奏嘛
Katrina: Anyway, just connect the accompaniment.
Katrina: 连全民k歌伴奏
Katrina: Connect to the karaoke app accompaniment.
Jake:对  对
Jake: Right, right.
Katrina: 然后自己自己练就行
Katrina: And practice on your own.
Jake:嗯先唱两首歌
Jake: Hmm, let's sing two songs first.
Jake:然后室友问答是吗
Jake: Then a roommate Q&A, right?
Alice:卡拉自助是呗
Alice: It's a karaoke self-service, right?
Katrina: 卡拉自助晚上没有问答
Katrina: The karaoke self-service doesn't have a Q&A at night.
Katrina: 问答是下午那天定的
Katrina: The Q&A is scheduled for the afternoon.
Jake:对那那个内容是
Jake: Right, so the content is...
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 知识问答
Katrina: A knowledge quiz.
Katrina: 对明天准备一下
Katrina: Yeah, let's prepare it for tomorrow.
Shure: 对明天准备一下
Shure: Yeah, let's prepare for tomorrow.
Katrina: QQ给我们出一个
Katrina: QQ will create one for us.
Lucia:写一下到楼上写一下
Lucia: Write it down, go upstairs and write it.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure: 然后大家记得通知自己的嘉宾
Shure: And remember to notify your guests.
Shure: 就是带一点闲置的二手物品
Shure: To bring some idle second-hand items.
Shure: 来进行拍卖
Shure: For auction.
Shure: 交换好吧
Shure: For exchange, alright?
Katrina: 这个闲置二手物品是交换给谁
Katrina: Who are these idle second-hand items for?
Katrina: 交换给我们
Katrina: For us?
Katrina: 还是他们
Katrina: Or them?
Katrina: 交换就是拍卖吧
Katrina: Exchange means auction, right?
Shure: 就是谁谁都可以来买
Shure: Anyone can buy them.
Shure: 就是比如说好的
Shure: For example, okay.
Shure: 我现在拍卖这个
Shure: I'm auctioning this now.
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This, this.
Shure: 我珍藏多年的酱香型白酒
Shure: My treasured sauce-flavored liquor.
Shure: 嗯自
Shure: Since...
Shure: 打我爷爷那年
Shure: The year my grandpa made it.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 对我这是做了一个违背祖宗的决定
Shure: Yes, I'm making a decision against my ancestors' will.
Shure: 今天把这瓶酒拍卖给大家了
Shure: Today, I'm auctioning this bottle of liquor.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后我觉得这瓶酒的起拍价是
Shure: So I think the starting price for this bottle is...
Alice:两块
Alice: Two bucks.
Shure: 两个一钩一钩币
Shure: Two "Y-gou" coins.
Shure: 好吧我们就叫一钩币
Shure: Alright, we'll call it "Y-gou" coin.
Jake:好一钩币可以一个coin
Jake: Okay, one "Y-gou" coin can be one coin.
Tasha:一个coin一钩
Tasha: One coin, one Y-gou.
Jake:很虚拟啊这个
Jake: It's very virtual.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 我们把每个那个小币都上链吧
Shure: Let's put each little coin on the chain.
Shure: 给他哈哈哈
Shure: Give it to him, haha.
Shure: 都想说哈哈
Shure: Everyone wants to say it, haha.
Lucia:多少数啊
Lucia:可以把它注一下
Lucia: Can you note it down?
Shure: 一勾臂
Shure: One elbow bend.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:对对对好
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, good.
Shure: 可以那就这么定了
Shure: Okay, let's settle on that.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 然后明天商量一下具体的细则
Shure: Then let's discuss the details tomorrow.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Just
Shure: 复现一下
Shure: Reenact it.
Shure: 我们
Shure: We
Jake:再捋一遍那个时间线啊
Jake: Review the timeline again.
Katrina: 三点啊 2点半到3点是
Katrina: Three o'clock, 2:30 to 3:00 is
Alice:嘉宾入场
Alice: Guest entry.
Katrina: 嘉宾入场
Katrina: Guest entry.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Tasha:呦
Tasha: Yo.
Jake:2点半到3点
Jake: 2:30 to 3:00.
Jake:对嘉宾入场
Jake: Yes, guest entry.
Jake:3点开始
Jake: Start at 3:00.
Jake:赚钱是吧
Jake: To make money, right?
Katrina: 对赚钱
Katrina: Yes, to make money.
Katrina: 是自我介绍嘛
Katrina: It's the self-introduction, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 对自我介绍
Shure: Yes, self-introduction.
Jake:班饼开始自我介绍
Jake: Ban Bing starts self-introduction.
Jake:三点开始自我介绍
Jake: Start self-introduction at 3:00.
Shure: 或者是讲故事
Shure: Or tell a story.
Jake:呃给多少钱呢
Jake: Uh, how much money to give?
Shure: 看我们心情给
Shure: Depends on our mood.
Shure: 对就是我们作为家
Shure: Yes, we as the judges.
Jake:就我们作为评委是吧
Jake: We as the judges, right?
Jake:评委评委
Jake: Judges, judges.
Jake:我们就坐着小板凳
Jake: We'll just sit on little stools.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Katrina: 那一上来就让他们自我介绍嘛
Katrina: Why don't we start by having them introduce themselves?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Shure: 我们先表演节目暖场
Shure: Let's warm up the crowd with a performance first.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Katrina: 表演什么节目
Katrina: What performance?
Shure: 我们给大家唱一个
Shure: We could sing something for everyone.
Shure: 哈哈哈我给大家咬个打火机
Shure: Haha, or I could bite a lighter for you all.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:咬个什么打火机
Alice: Bite what lighter?
Katrina: 他才艺很
Katrina: He's very talented.
Shure: 你不知道这个梗吗
Shure: You don't know this joke?
Shure: 没活就咬打火机吧
Shure: When there's nothing to do, just bite a lighter.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 你这就是
Shure: That's it.
Shure: 哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, alright, alright.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 那天说了先干嘛来着
Katrina: What did we say we'd do first that day?
Katrina: 自我介绍前面还有一个环节
Katrina: There was something before the self-introductions.
Katrina: 我看我拍的照片
Katrina: Let me check the photos I took.
Jake:还有一个game
Jake: There was a game.
Jake:game before party
Jake: A game before the party.
Katrina: 先知识问答来着好像
Katrina: Was it a quiz or something?
Shure: game before party是啥来着
Shure: What was the game before the party?
Jake:拼那个拼图吗
Jake: Was it a puzzle?
Shure: 啊啊啊对对对
Shure: Ah, yes, that's right.
Alice:那个得拼
Alice: That puzzle needs to be completed.
Tasha:那个的拼好
Tasha: That puzzle needs to be finished.
Lucia:不容易拼好
Lucia: Not easy to finish.
Jake:哈哈哈很难拼哦
Jake: Haha, it's really hard.
Lucia:别打伞或者别的game
Lucia: Maybe no umbrellas or other games.
Jake:别打伞或者别的game
Jake: Maybe no umbrellas or other games.
Jake:还有就是藏东西在你们各种各地方
Jake: Also, we could hide stuff in various places.
Lucia:复活节彩蛋
Lucia: Like Easter eggs.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 那有点
Shure: That would be...
Shure: 哦藏币是吧
Shure: Oh, hiding coins, right?
Jake:对藏币
Jake: Yeah, hiding coins.
Shure: :然后这个拿拿到就归他们
Shure: And whoever finds them gets to keep them.
Jake:是藏币
Jake: Yep, hiding coins.
Shure: 对对对一些散币对
Shure: Yes, yes, yes, some scattered coins.
Shure: 1,000 来
Shure: 1,000, come on.
Shure: 哈哈哈我们我们撒一些币
Shure: Hahaha, we will scatter some coins.
Shure: 简称撒币
Shure: We call it scattering coins.
Lucia:你先挖矿环节
Lucia: You first, the mining part.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:对对行
Jake: Right, right, okay.
Jake:那明天我们撒就撒
Jake: Then tomorrow we'll scatter.
Jake:对明天我们当撒撒币
Jake: Yes, tomorrow we'll scatter coins.
Jake:嗯哈哈
Jake: Hmm, haha.
Jake:明天撒撒币
Jake: Scatter coins tomorrow.
Shure: 明天撒撒币
Shure: Scatter coins tomorrow.
Jake:撒撒币啊
Jake: Scatter coins.
Jake:我们50个币
Jake: We have 50 coins.
Jake:我们多少币
Jake: How many coins do we have?
Lucia:我们多少币
Lucia: How many coins do we have?
Lucia:150个
Lucia: 150.
Jake:150个币
Jake: 150 coins.
Shure: 150个
Shure: 150.
Jake:撒他
Jake: Scatter them.
Shure: 流 流通
Shure: Circulate, circulate.
Tasha: 50个我
Tasha: 50 for me.
Jake:不行
Jake: No.
Jake:哈哈哈有点太多了
Jake: Hahaha, that's a bit too much.
Shure: 流通有点太多
Shure: Circulating is a bit too much.
Lucia:20
Lucia: 20.
Jake:撒他20个币
Jake: Scatter 20 coins.
Jake:哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Lucia:光撒的只是一部分OK
Lucia: Scattering is just a part, okay.
Jake:对撒他20个币
Jake: Yes, scatter 20 coins.
Jake:然后
Jake: And then.
Lucia: 不能全撒
Lucia: Can't scatter all.
Jake:不能全撒
Jake: Can't scatter all.
Jake:对要保证金融市场事从无
Jake: Yes, we need to ensure the financial market is intact.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 我是这边记得是两点半到3点入场
Katrina: I remember it’s from 2:30 to 3:00 for entry.
Katrina: 然后introduction and Q&A是3点到3:40
Katrina: Then the introduction and Q&A is from 3:00 to 3:40.
Katrina: 嗯那这个暖场游戏是啥时候呢
Katrina: Hmm, so when is the warm-up game?
Katrina: 就在2点半到3点之间
Katrina: Between 2:30 and 3:00.
Jake:对 2点半到三点
Jake: Yeah, from 2:30 to 3:00.
Tasha:暖场是什么游戏
Tasha: What’s the warm-up game?
Jake:来的人就来
Jake: Whoever comes, comes.
Katrina: 找币
Katrina: Find coins.
Jake:对找币
Jake: Yeah, find coins.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Katrina: 找币
Katrina: Find coins.
Katrina: 然后想玩那个拼图的就玩拼图
Katrina: And if you want to do puzzles, do puzzles.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Jake:然后如果拼起来的话
Jake: And if you complete it...
Katrina: 可以奖励
Katrina: There’s a reward.
Katrina: 拼不起来的
Katrina: If you can’t finish it...
Lucia:拼不起来放心吧
Lucia: Don’t worry, you won’t finish it.
Alice:要不按照块拼吧
Alice: How about we do it piece by piece?
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
修确：就是你拼到几个
Shure: Like, how many pieces you complete...
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 那总共有几个块来着
Shure: So, how many pieces are there in total?
Jake:大概几十个吧
Jake: About dozens, I guess.
Alice:好几十个吧
Alice: Yeah, dozens.
Katrina: 他们有个就圆形的拼图很难拼
Katrina: They have this round puzzle that’s super hard.
Tasha:三十
Tasha: Thirty.
Jake:你们作为每拼起来的人
Jake: For each one you complete...
Shure: 就是
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 每
Shure: Each...
Katrina: 就是所有的动物很不规则
Katrina: All the animal shapes are so irregular.
Jake:就就大概点评一下给个稍为
Jake: Just, like, give a brief comment and a small reward.
Jake:随便给点钱吧要不就
Jake: How about just give some money?
Katrina: 反正他们那天拼了一个小时
Katrina: They spent an hour on it the other day.
Shure: 每拼进去多少个
Shure: For each piece you complete...
Shure: 然后我们给
Shure: We give...
Shure: 就比如说每拼进5个
Shure: Like, for every 5 pieces...
Shure: 我可以给你一个
Shure: I can give you one.
Shure: 你要能拼
Shure: If you can finish...
Tasha:拼5个就给一个币啊
Tasha: You get one coin for every 5 pieces?
Tasha:你这小抠搜
Tasha: You’re so stingy.
Tasha:抠搜的
Tasha: So stingy.
Alice:你知道那个有多难吗
Alice: Do you know how hard that is?
Lucia:知道有多难吗
Lucia: Do you know how hard it is?
Alice:我都快拼瞎了
Alice: I'm almost going blind from working so hard.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No
Shure: 你我
Shure: You and I
Jake:哈哈哈一个币很难挣的
Jake: Hahaha, it's really hard to earn a coin.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 你这是破坏市场
Shure: You're disrupting the market.
Jake:你知道现在一个
Jake: Do you know now one
Tasha:你才是
Tasha:你知道现在一个矿业吗
Tasha: Do you know now one mining industry
Tasha:真的剥削你知道吗
Tasha: Really exploiting, you know?
Jake:一个矿业多少钱吗
Jake: Do you know how much one mining industry costs?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Lucia: 你说是big矿业吗
Lucia: Are you talking about big mining?
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Lucia:他说一个矿多少钱
Lucia: He said how much one mine costs.
Lucia:我说是比特币吗
Lucia: I said is it Bitcoin?
Lucia:哈哈哈这差不多吧
Lucia: Hahaha, it's almost the same, right?
Jake:一开始也不值钱对吧
Jake: It wasn't worth much at first, right?
Alice:我们都快拼瞎了
Alice: We're almost going blind from working so hard.
Lucia:那你真得把咱这上链上链
Lucia: Then you really need to get this on the blockchain.
Lucia:给他注成NFT算了
Lucia: Turn it into an NFT.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right.
Alice:没关系要不然就按时间吧
Alice: It's okay, otherwise, just do it by time.
Shure: 阿猫阿猫通他们都在NFT
Shure: Ah Mao, Ah Mao Tong, they're all into NFTs.
Alice:他们嗯
Alice: They are, hmm.
Alice:不管拼成什么样
Alice: No matter how hard we work.
Shure: 元宇宙 我元你家的激发宇宙
Shure: Metaverse, I will ignite your universe.
Alice:能坐上15分钟就给他个两三个之类的
Alice: If you can sit for 15 minutes, give them two or three of those.
Jake:什么呀什么东西
Jake: What? What are you talking about?
Lucia:木子膏呀
Lucia: Mu Zi Gao.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 你不知道这
Shure: You don't know this
Lucia:有一首歌
Lucia: There's a song
Shure: 是的热狗的一首歌叫做NFT
Shure: Yeah, a song by Hotdog called NFT.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:听懂一个词
Jake: I understood one word.
Lucia: 感觉都是哔哔哔
Lucia: It feels like beep beep beep.
Lucia:哈哈哈对自带消音效果
Lucia: Hahaha, yeah, it's like it comes with its own censoring effect.
Shure: 可以听一下这个词
Shure: You can listen to this word.
Katrina: 那就这样
Katrina: So that's it.
Katrina: 3点哈哈哈
Katrina: 3 o'clock, hahaha
Jake:行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Katrina: 3点到3:40是他们自我介绍
Katrina: From 3 to 3:40, it's their self-introductions.
Katrina: 和我们的知识问答
Katrina: And our Q&A session.
Katrina: 然后3:40到4:20是我们host part
Katrina: Then from 3:40 to 4:20, it's our host part.
Katrina: 就是我们介绍我们每个人的东西
Katrina: We'll introduce our stuff.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 4:20到5点是他们介绍他们带来的东西
Katrina: From 4:20 to 5, they introduce what they brought.
Katrina: 拍卖嗯
Katrina: Auction, yeah.
Katrina: 然后5点半左右就是订的
Katrina: And around 5:30, we have the order.
Katrina: 然后就是披萨
Katrina: Then it's pizza.
Katrina: 然后6点
Katrina: And at 6,
Katrina: 6点多的时候就可以开始唱
Katrina: Around 6, we can start singing.
Katrina: 唱歌什么的
Katrina: Singing and stuff.
Katrina: 晚上就指定了
Katrina: In the evening, it's set.
Katrina: 唱歌好像
Katrina: Singing, I think.
Jake:对晚上没啥大吃
Jake: Yeah, nothing big to eat at night.